Jumping right in, Project Compilation.
Before we look at the minutia of what an Unreal project is,
let's take a look at what we've got available to us
when working with Compilation in the Unreal Engine.
The Unreal Engine provides custom building methods
via the Unreal Build Tool or the UBT.
This unique tool will build
the engine's reflection system.
It will integrate any C++ code with blueprints.
It'll deal with any replication backend
and deal with serialization.
The Unreal Build Tool is capable of spinning up
a wide selection of build configurations
that developers can leverage
during the development cycle of the project.
On the left, we have a sample of the configurations
that Unreal offers,
whilst on the right we have the targets
that we can build to.
To elaborate further on the configurations,
let's look at what each one offers us as engineers.
Debug, in this configuration,
the entire engine and game code is unoptimized.
This will be slower than any of the other configurations,
but it will give us a lot more access
to debug information.
We've then got Debug Game,
and this is similar to Debug,
but only the game code is unoptimized.
To be more precise,
this covers the code within our project,
but not the engine.
We've then got Development.
This configuration enables all but the most
time-consuming engine and game code optimizations.
From there, we've got Test.
This configuration optimizes the code,
but allows for debug console commands
and testing tools to be used,
such as stats and profiling tools.
This configuration does not work with an editor target.
Finally, we've got Shipping,
and this is our fully optimized code with stats,
profiling tools, and console commands removed.
And again, this does not work with editor targets.
These configurations are paired
with a particular target in mind,
which are listed on the right-hand side of this slide.
We've got Client and Server.
These targets build exactly what you think.
It will compile your project for a client or for a server.
Client code is stripped away
from any server-based targets and vice versa.
We can wrap sections of code with server code
or not with server code
to exclude code from particular deployments.
We've then got Editor,
and this target is unique
in that it will compile for all targets,
and we'll discuss this in more depth soon.
We've then got an Empty target,
and this is a standalone target for single-player games.
It'll be a single standalone game.
And this will include both server and client code.
Any code that is preprocessed, as we mentioned,
will be included in this build.
Just a few notes on the Editor itself.
The Editor is far more
than just a scripting tool for other teams.
Aside from providing a staggering array
of environment authoring tools and asset setup frameworks,
it allows developers to test their project
in both a single and a multiplayer environment.
This is why the Editor target is so unique.
It allows us to compile every target
that we could possibly want,
and allows us to use them all simultaneously.
The Play and Editor features
can spin up more than one user and a dedicated server,
all from within the Editor itself,
giving us a fantastic and easily accessible representation
of our project post deploy.
It's a common misconception
that Blueprint is for scripting and for prototyping.
This simply isn't the case.
Entire projects can and have been made in Blueprint alone
with no real downsides,
because it's a tool much like anything else.
If using Blueprint suits your studio's needs,
then it absolutely should be considered
as a primary implementation.
Projects can be written in both C++ and Blueprint
using the Epic Launcher version of the engine,
so you don't need the source.
Whilst having access to the source is fantastic,
it's entirely optional.
We can grab the engine from the Epic Games Launcher
and dive right in.
The Epic Launcher version of the engine
is simply a pre-compiled version of that source.
It's worth noting that we won't have access
to the source symbols by default, however.
They will need to be downloaded separately.
If you'd like to have access to the source code,
however, it is freely available.
It's available on the Unreal Git repo
and through the Unreal Perforce if you're a licensee.
It's very useful if you intend to make engine changes.
The symbols for the editor, however,
can be downloaded from the launcher as pictured.